vor lecker wobei er nie gemacht das ist
jetzt echt so gut schmeckt doch tischfuß
lecker von optiker es neues im endeffekt
ein muss für jeden fan
[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute machen wir orio
sushi also süßes sushi aus wo zwei
zutaten vielleicht nehme ich dann noch
eine dritte oder vierte dazu aber das
grundrezept besteht wirklich aus nur
zwei zutaten ich kriege einen anruf ist
kannst du sie ignorieren auf jeden fall
machen wir eine variante jetzt mit orio
ich hatte vor ein paar jahren mit kokos
gemacht hätte die bounty rolle genannt
habe ich gern das rezept nach dem video
an verlinkt ihr euch um die info-box ich
starte jetzt in dem ich die hausse
einfach nur erstmalig halbiere und dann
müssen wir diese weiße creme raus
schaden und die kekse kommen dann in den
mixer falls jetzt kanister hat macht ja
einen ganz alten trick einfach in einen
gefrierbeutel rein dann richtig lange
mit einem nudelholz draufschlagen bis es
richtig schön fein ist
[Musik]
so nachdenken die texte dann richtig
fein gemahlen habt ihr einfach nur noch
einen schluck milch dazu oder eben so
viele stücke bis die masse richtig schön
festwirt und ihr sieht quasi
zusammendrücken könnt und wir machen
jetzt weiter mit der ich schon etwas
milch füllung gesagt aber es ist
tatsächlich keine milch drin nimmt jetzt
diese erfüllung und da kommt jetzt auch
ein schluck milch rein weiß ist ein
bisschen trocken und so wird es einfach
noch mal so ein bisschen cremiger und
dann wollte ich ja noch eine frucht
füllung dazu machen und dafür würde ich
mir gleich aus dem tiefkühler einfach
mal früchte dich da habt ihr
[Musik]
für die frucht füllung brauchen wir nur
drei zutaten dafür nehme ich jetzt
einfach tiefgekühlte je mehr ihr könnt
eigentlich jede frucht nehmen die ihr da
habt ihr könnt jetzt denn die oder es
gibt ja auch diesen bären nächsten
stelle mir da auch ganz gut vor also da
kommt jetzt einfach was damit dazu die
hat es jetzt macht mich an bei mir
bringst und um das ganze natürlich fest
zu kriegen damit sich das gut auf freuen
lässt weise stärke einfach mit rein
geben und er virtuell könnt ihr noch ein
bisschen mit zucker nach helfen wenn
jetzt die früchte irgendwie euch zu
sauer sind oder so dann das individuelle
damit einfach abschmecken mein verbrauch
ich das heute nicht aber könnte ich da
auch noch mal so ein telefon oder so
eine dazugeben sollte einfach nur
verrührt funktioniert eigentlich ganz
gut wenn die jetzt groß sind einmal
verrührt und gleich zerfallen sie dann
wenn sie immer kleiner und wenn ihr das
ganze dann einmal hochkocht es auf kocht
dann liegt das alles andere ist dabei
immer früheren das ist ganz wichtig
damit ihr unten nichts anbrennt und
danach finden wir das oam
beziehungsweise sein ich mache so ich
spüre dass und passiert das dann
[Musik]
jetzt steht die basis schon mal so wir
haben den oreo teig einmal auffrischen
frischkäse seite auf frischhaltefolie
ausgebreitet das zählt am besten wenn
ihr noch mal frischhaltefolie oben
drüber liegt und einfach mit einem
nudelholz schön gerade aus reute und
dabei zusieht das echt so eine schöne
recht aktive form bekommt es muss auch
nicht so perfekt sein aber ihr gerade es
ist desto schöner ist das endergebnis
und jetzt kommt quasi einmal diese orio
creme und ob die wird dann schön glatt
verstrichen und ich finde auch wenn ihr
jetzt nur diese unternehmen dann ist es
schon so ein bisschen mager also wenn
ihr da jetzt einfach noch diese frucht
denn diese frucht kompott vision was
dank nochmal oben drüber legt dann habt
ihr einfach viel mehr von und die rolle
ist auch ein bisschen dicker und es
gleicht so ein bisschen die süße aus und
sobald ihr das dann auch verstrichen
habt ihr wieder sushi einfach auf und
ich gebe euch noch einen tipp hier oben
könnt ihr noch einen halben zentimeter
frei lassen damit ihr diese füllung
quasi nicht ausdrückt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die oso skiroller durfte jetzt eine
stunde ins gefrierfach ihr braucht auch
wirklich mindestens eine stunde damit
unterscheiden können zum schneiden nehmt
ihr euch so ein schönes messer mit
wellenschliff ja und dann ist das rezept
schon fertig ist das natürlich japans
reaktion gespannt
[Musik]
hierauf trompete nicht so einfach zur
seite zu tun
ist der verein aber böse gut gehalten
haben die sind so schön sind jetzt
fertig habe ich noch umgezogen ist
vermerkt dass ich hab ich ja auch
umgezogen selbst gemerkt habt aber ich
war nicht nutzen dann hast du
sogar wissen gehört
hatten recht ich hab keinen bock aber
ist schon viel zu lange her rückt ein so
sind wir so ist wenn das ist echt viel
spaß mit den stäbchen ich sage es ist
unmöglich auch mit stäbchen zu etwas zu
schwer oder schon oder also sollten wir
uns um sms in orio fruchtige sushi holst
gesagt euro vielleicht komme ich jetzt
mal ich mache das mit stäbchen ist mir
egal aber ich habe ihr dringend also
eigentlich brauchst du das willst du das
machst du denn hier
muss dazu sagen
fotos gemacht so sicher sind wie überall
anders ist schon das wird schon sehr
schnell weicht das muss man dazu sagen
muss klopp vor lecker so gut dass wir
die frucht rein gemacht haben ohne die
wäre es mir zu süß holen wollte er nie
gemacht das ist echt so gut schmecken
haben natürlich nicht wahr ausbau weil
das ist so ein einfaches rezept aber die
cocos rolle war auch richtig lecker die
müsst euch auch unbedingt angucken im
endeffekt ein muss für jeden fan und das
dachte ich süß drückt
leckerbissen bereit sind so ganz auf das
was du von optik und kuchen
immer so viele filme haben japanischen
als nachtisch also 12 stück dann dann
bereits leer doch also ein
wirklich muss
also das nachmachen ja
nicht mehr das reden immer viel gerede
zu beraten wie solche voraus ist ein
kohle kunde variante und alle die hier
so mögen müssen das jetzt machen wir das
sagt voll die verbindung sagt geschmack
ist war das identisch sind ja genau naja
ok lieben hinterlassen mir auf meinen
daumen nach oben wenn ihr bis
hingeschaut habe und ja
also
leute die
sie haben es aber auch weggehauen
[Musik]